i was at a party okay
long time ago party in seattle
small party maybe like 14 people
and this girl that we know that i used
to work with
she's having sex with a dude in the room
at my friend's room
and they have sex and dude has a couple
more drinks and high fives people it was
funny because there aren't many people
there so you know people are [ __ ]
right
and walks out and we know the girl and
she comes out and she was i just
couldn't help it we were like yeah no
problem get your [ __ ] on
and she was like this was so funny she
was like i didn't really know him whose
friend is that
and we were like we thought you brought
nobody knew
who the [ __ ] guy was he came out
high-fived everybody took a couple shots
and left we were like got
he went home was like dude i was walking
down the street nobody knew this
i saw a party went in this hot chick
[ __ ] her drank their drinks and left
dude
were they cool pretty cool dude i was
like
i was thinking the same thing i'm like
that's the best night that dude has ever
had
ever he's probably still telling the
story now he's like i i to to be walking
home or whatever
even if you're and if i think i know the
pressure talking about smoking hot
crazy dude crazy he must have lived in
the building
or something like i like parties yeah
i'm gonna swing by here
and if she's hot let's do this
what a great night where do you fall on
people
getting super close to wild animals not
my thing
pros cons yeah pro
i get a cool instagram pic with a
grizzly bear one con
heats me asks for yeah live on instagram
tv
you know what i'm saying that's exactly
where i fall like oh was he taking
pictures of the wild animals so he
showed me he was like there was this one
there was a herd of bison that were
across the street
and i couldn't it wasn't close enough so
i hopped the fence
and i'm like stop right there was the
camera crew with him or something did he
do it for the tv show no just for his
instagram jacob
i agree i go what i go how is that has
you not seen the videos what bison do to
people
dude have you ever seen those videos yes
have you ever seen a buffalo
in person i grew up in [ __ ] colorado
we see buffalo they're massive they're
massive and they're not cool no here's
what i would tell you
they're hippos covered in hair and horns
bison or hippos
if you're if you're an animal and you
have a dirt hippo
boom bob this could be you jacob
look look in the air
and look at that boom [ __ ] oh it's a
hairy rhinoceros
that's what that is when you have knives
on your face you're not friendly
that's not but again just pros cons dude
go to the zoo if you want to get close
that's my saying like what's the why why
why why are you going he said i really
wanted to see a bear
what you want to see a bear i have no
desire to do that no
i don't i've seen a bear on google yeah
yeah i've seen what the zoo i mean sure
he's depressed and like
broken yeah and he's wearing he's
wearing a hat yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's like that's like
an alien come here like i want you out
humans and go
to prison oh like looks i'm like they
look pretty sad yeah
that's what we do with animals hang in
there they look real sad love is blind
is tough right
i get it i didn't get through all of
life oh i found it boring
halfway through i was like i got it yeah
whatever happened to you
yes that happens every year like me for
this that was me in sopranos
what yeah three episodes into it i'm
good no you don't get it
three episodes three when's the last
time you watched it i went back and
watched the whole
first season um four months i've been
home
recently yeah dude sopranos really
what part of it do you felt like you got
it was
i wasn't that interested in compared to
the tv we have now yeah
compared to that we've just it's so much
better now
what would you say is so much better
everything
huh storylines the editing the acting
what what show in particular would you
say is so much better
besides yellowstone well that is so much
better than this
for sure i'd say narcos all seasons are
better i haven't seen any narcos
but i haven't seen titanic either so
yeah that's fine though people have been
on me this week about not
titanic holy [ __ ] man you do yourself a
service man i gotta tell you i had no
idea so many of your fans were big
titanic guys
they're guys in their feelings like how
are your little ones how do you not see
this
i haven't seen titanic i haven't seen
the notebook i'm not in my face no but
i'm not
yeah but titanic's a solid movie isn't
it just like
it's not you wouldn't consider that to
be a love story
yeah a chicken flick no no not really
because leonardo dicaprio it's that
titanic so it's a you know it's it's
pretty brutal at the end
yeah uh rose is a bit of a [ __ ] right
she's
really cocked he's in leo the whole time
yeah jack
and then like they could have took turns
on the on the
ship uh door which they were both
freezing you know
i mean true she could have shared a door
with him yeah
i think about it like we could have
taken turns so i didn't freeze today i
also feel like i've been told
the movie so many times that like you
got it
i think that's where i'm at with
sopranos got it
but you don't though now i know people
can be upset about this
but you watch the wire no i watched the
first three episodes and i was like i
got it
honestly i watched the first video wow
yeah we're the same yeah
all right i'll tell you what man that's
true blood it's okay i do watch true
blood i like that kind of campy stuff
but i'm gonna get into i'll go back and
watch a wyatt
oh it's heavy and towards the end it
sucks but you watch breaking bad
another one got it no you
i'm gonna tell you right now a hundred
percent breaking bad
got it you don't got it i got it how
many episodes
uh i did four no you don't got it you
don't got it
breaking bad i know no man i know
dude no man watch ozark nah
i watched the first three episodes and i
got it why
it's so well done and the writer
sheridan you'd love all his stuff
are you telling me if you were telling
me one out of the three yellowstone
the wire or what was the other one you
just said ozark ozark which one what
should i watch
yellowstone fantastic okay kevin carson
name one bad thing he's ever done oh no
dude
i'm team power now you could argue water
world but i found it entertaining as a
kid
i am team kevin question with skills
sign me up yeah man and by the way
he was so
[ __ ] good as a young dude i mean
bodyguard come on what was the fir
the first pair of shoes you bought where
you were like
these are [ __ ] oh jordan fives the
laser reds
yeah you still have them no i [ __ ]
wish
i couldn't wear them but yeah i was that
was when i was a kid
yeah i did do like now now it's now it's
a little different like i posted this uh
instagram post what are those jordan 5's
look like is that what
uh they would be just a
one over chin those me and my brother
both got those
the fire rest my favorite shoe of all
time the jordan ones are my favorite
shoe of all time
uh but those are the most sentimental
shoe
that is i bought them from my brother
when they came out i bought them for my
brother
how much were they doing back then i
don't know we were kids that
had been 100 bucks i guess for kid shoes
yeah dude i still for me
i still remember those white red and
black
old school for me they're the first
jordans i remember
seeing and to me those are still my
all-time favorite they might be the ones
i don't know but they
probably the ones the white the white
red and black yeah the ones
i had never i remember when he first
started wearing those shoes they were so
yeah those are them i can't believe you
played basketball on those you ever like
those are not
they're not those right there they're
not fun to to
like there's no support in them no
there's but there's
going on so but even like the like these
the like dunks or the hotness right now
dunks are the hype beasts
what people don't know dunks are
skateboarding shoes yeah these are stiff
as [ __ ]
like if i if i walk far like let's say
i'm in new york i can't wear dunks
my feet will because i'm 37 my feet will
be destroyed by the time you get back to
the hotel yeah you're also
37 you're wearing furry orange shoes so
yeah but it doesn't matter
fur no fur python leather
these are made for [ __ ] skateboarding
and they're stiff as [ __ ]
that's why dude the reason i stick with
puma they're so comfy
they're so comfortable and i'm at the oh
i told you what happened to me old man
this weekend
and i'm at an old man stage in my life
but pumas are dope man like you can wear
those with jeans or anything yeah yeah
absolutely
are you have you ever thought about
designing a shoe
i did one for this brand new york brand
called greats
i did one uh fire and kid collab with
them yeah
and uh yeah that was great well how did
that happen
was that 100 your you got to design them
yep and how did you go about like did
you
look at a lot of well they have a base
that you have to start from
oh they're oh yeah they're right here so
so great they're they're leather shoes
so i couldn't get too crazy
because i like crazy shoes but when
you're appealing to the mask you can't
do crazy
so these are i like them man you know
what i also like
see i like the thick on the bottom yeah
i know a lot of
people don't know great they're they're
amazing they're crushing their big time
now
they want to return my call shout out to
ryan
but this is i mean these these sold out
in minutes yeah those are super dope
yeah
if your son is 16 and he's like hey i'm
gonna have some friends over
you cool if we stay here all night but
we drink where are you with that kind of
stuff
nothing worse than the cool parent yeah
but there's nothing worse but at the
same time
but at the same time do you want them
out drinking
and drinking do you know what i mean
like that's that's the thing
i i i hope he i ra
he's raised where he's makes good
decisions where you're
to do that stuff but just do it
responsibly i think
to me i gave jacob an uber
card and i said i don't i never see a
charge on this that doesn't say uber
yes but like this is for
if you need a ride i'm never going to
question it by the way even if it's two
in the afternoon i'm never going to say
why did you need it so
take advantage and be safe yeah take
advantage of that but
if i ever hear about you getting in a
car
i'm gonna drop i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you yeah there was no dude
the the madness i ever got at him i
found a vape in his room
uh tobacco how old was he fifteen or
sixteen
and i said to him kids are doing i said
listen i'm gonna tell you this and this
is just your one
chance i'm gonna tell you this right now
do not
smoke vapes do not get addicted to this
[ __ ] no were you still smoking weed
every day when you're telling this yeah
but this he didn't know that
oh okay i'm like do not do not
and i'm serious man i can't get you
hooked on this this is
a hard habit to break and uh man
that [ __ ] and by the way yeah i
snoop in my kid's room
if you don't snoop in your kid's room
i'm a snooper and by the way and i
and i don't i didn't i didn't i snoop
around and yeah
everybody's gone
i'm a snooper i heard that's your studio
though yeah i know but
jen you got that i was like oh what's
this you it's up for you
you're getting a gun huh okay you did
snoop
i'm a snooper you gotta snoop i gotta
see what's going on man
my thing with
is this i didn't bust him on everything
because i didn't want him to know i was
in his [ __ ] yeah but i want to make sure
he's not doing things that are harmful
to him